Today I want to look at three questions.
Why did this war between the United
States and Iran start?
How will this war end? And what will
happen after this war ends? And to
answer these three questions, we need we
need to discuss the nature and structure
of our reality.
And the first thing you need to
understand which is very hard is that
our world is a hallucination. It's a
collective fantasy. All right. So to
understand this idea let's look at
Plato's allegory of the cave. Okay.
Plato,
sorry,
Plato's
allegory of the cave.
And so in this cave, we're deep inside
the earth and it's dark. There's some
light coming in, but not much. And we're
all chained in a line together, okay?
And there's about a million of us. We're
on the floor and we're chained to the
ground and we can't really move. We
can't get up. We can't move around. Even
our necks are shackled. So, we can't
turn around and see the world around us.
Okay? So, there's about a million of us
all sitting down and staring at a wall
together. Okay? And this wall is blank.
Behind us is great fire.
And
there are people around this fire. Okay,
they we don't know who they are,
but they are free to move around. And
what they do is this. They take
uh puppets
and then they reflect the puppets onto
the wall creating shadows.
And we are mesmerized by these shadows
because before we're staring at a blank
wall and now there are these moving
shadows and we think these shadows are
real because we don't know any better.
So we give them names. Okay, we give
them names and we create a language in
order to tell stories
about these shadows and this becomes
really our collective reality. Okay. So
another way of saying this is that
reality
is a collective conscious
which become which is really a a
hallucination.
Okay. All right. So there are certain
things about this reality that we need
to keep in mind. Okay. So first of all
what's really important to understand is
that what creates this reality is our
conscious
our imagination our perception
not anyone else us. Okay. So in other
words the wealth in the society is our
conscious
consciousness
the amount of thought we put into
something.
And so let me give an example. Let's
just say that I were to ask you to make
a vase
to sell on the marketplace. Okay? While
you're making this vase, if you are
listening to music, if you are chatting
with a friend, if you're not fully
conscious and focused and attentive
about making this vase, it won't be very
good.
But if you are completely focused on
creating the most beautiful vase you can
and you're not distracted by anything
then this vase will be beautiful and
therefore more valuable in the
marketplace. Okay. So in other words, it
is our conscious attention that creates
wealth in this in this uh world and it
is really money our capital that
extracts and stores our consciousness
and turns it into wealth. All right. So
that's a really important concept that
most people don't understand but you
need to understand this if we are to
understand the nature of reality itself.
Okay. So that's the first thing you you
need to understand. This reality is
structured to extract our consciousness
in order to create wealth for the elite
for these people. Okay? And historically
there have been different mechanisms
that you can use in order to extract and
store wealth. All right? So you have
maybe religion. Okay? And so think of
pyramids,
right? Because pyramids in Egypt are
able to focus your attention and
motivate you to do certain actions,
okay? To engage in religious worship.
But really temples.
So that's one form
of capital. Another form of of capital
of course is the idea of stories. Homer,
right? Homer is the father of Greek
civilization because he wrote the Iliad
in the Odyssey which is able to focus
people's attentions and drive them to
great things. Then you of course in
today's world you have uh the Bible
and uh the main mechanism to extract and
store wealth in today's world of course
is the US dollar.
Now, but there's another force that's
being created in order to replace the US
dollar and this is called artificial
intelligence.
All right. So, what we'll discuss later
on is that there's actually a war going
on for the soul of humanity for the
human consciousness between US dollar
the old world world order and artificial
intelligence the new world world order.
Okay? But I want you to keep this in
mind. Right? All right. So that's the
first thing I want you to understand.
Second thing that I need you to
understand is that these people they
we don't know who they are. Okay. But
what we do know is that they don't force
us to do anything. There's not enough of
them. Okay. The way they power is
through manipulation
and trickery and deception.
And we know this because in playing
alley with a cave one day, for whatever
reason, one guy decides, you know what?
I feel as though this is not the real
world. I feel as though there's
something outside this cave. So, he or
she starts messing around with the
chains and and realizes these aren't
chains. These are just like ropes. I can
just like get rid of them. And this this
chain around my neck, it's like a it's
like a ribbon. I I snap it off. And he
doesn't know why he does this, but he
does this. He does do this. And he when
he does this, they don't even care. Like
whatever, man. Do whatever you want. And
so he releases himself. He's blind
because he's been in dark all his life,
but somehow he recognized that there's
this light, okay, outside the cave. And
he and he is compelled to this light. So
he's walking, stumbling to this light
and again they are like watching him
like we don't care. Do whatever you want
man. They don't stop him. He goes out
into the light and now he's outside and
it's pure light. Okay, he's left the
cave and at first he's in pain and he
struggles to re reorientate himself to
this new world. But then eventually he
falls in love with this world. It's a
beautiful world and it's like for him
heaven. And he's like, "Oh my god, this
is the real world. The cave is a fake
world that we created ourselves. Let me
go back there and tell everyone about
the truth." And when he goes back, they
again they leave. Don't stop him. Like
whatever you want, man. Do whatever you
want. Okay. So they who are in power,
you think they have an army, you think
they have magic and you think that
they're evil, but really all their power
rests on our belief in their power.
Okay, they themselves don't have any
power except to manipulate us. Okay,
that's something you need to understand.
The third thing you you need to
understand is that even though this is a
fake world,
people don't know this. They think it's
real. In fact, they believe it is so
real that they are willing to die for
it. So that when this man who's seen
heaven, who's seen the truth, who's come
back to tell everyone these chains that
you have aren't real.
we can break free and escape into a real
world if they if he dares to tell them
this together they will kill him. Okay,
do you understand? So in other words,
the reality is a hallucination. It's
created by us, but we fall in love with
it. We're so attached to it to it
psychologically and emotionally that if
anyone tells us it's fake, we kill them
for it. Okay. So, these three things I
want you to keep in mind as we explore
our world because our world is actually
just Plato's cave. All right. So, let me
show you how.
All right.
So,
you need a force in order to create this
reality to train us together. Okay. And
this force of course is called the
American Empire. All right. the empire.
Basically, just a military,
but they themselves
don't really want to control this world
because they're an army. Okay? So, what
they do is they allow the creation of a
financial order, a global financial
order, which then constructs the game
that we play. Okay? And these people
then uh construct the reality that we
live in. Okay? So this is the global
financial order and and what is this
global financial order? Well, at the
very top is something called the bank of
international settlements in bas of
Switzerland. Okay, the central bank of
central banks. Below them is the uh
world bank, the IMF, international
monetary fund which controls the rules
of the global financial order and then
below them are something called
potential banks. Okay. So the federal
reserve in United States, the bank of
bank um the people's bank of China in
China. Okay, the England in England.
Okay, so together they create the global
financial order. And what is the global
financial order? It's just to use the US
dollar as a main mechanism of wealth
extraction and wealth storage. Okay,
really simple. The US dollar. Another
way of of understanding these people is
is to think of them as the game masters.
Okay, the ones above us who constructed
the game and controlling the rules of
the game as we play it. Okay, the game
masters.
Okay. So once the game has been created
with the rules and incentives, now we
can play the game and this game is
called the global economy.
All right.
So when China trades with the United
States, when you go off um to Europe on
vacation, you're all participating in a
game created by the financial order.
Okay? And the purpose of this global
financial sorry this global economy is
to have everyone play as much as
possible so that wealth can be
transferred from the world to the United
States, the powers that be. Okay? And
they do this through two mechanisms. The
first is the US dollar. So every time
you use the US dollar, you're actually
paying a tax to America because America
has the power to print as much US
dollars as it wants. Okay. The second
way that uh it does this is through
something called price hierarchy. Okay.
A price harchy. So the global economy is
divided into tiers. Okay. So resources
are considered the cheapest
even though in reality it should be the
most expensive, right? Because resources
are resources are limited. They're
finite. Above resource of course is
manufacturing
and above manufacturing is knowledge
economy
and then the highest is finance. Okay.
Basically the game masters. All right.
So and as we can see once with this
price hockey in place what we can do now
is divide the world according to the
specialties. Okay. So resource of course
would be Russia,
Russia,
uh the Middle East, the GCC, okay, Saudi
Arabia, these places. Okay. So these
places provide resources. Manufacturing
then would be be China,
right? Knowledge would be Europe
and uh the five eyes. Okay, basically
the angle sphere, Canada, New Zealand,
Australia, Britain. Um and then finance
of course United States. Okay. Sorry.
The United States. All right. So as you
can see this is a system that benefits
United States and its allies to the to
the detriment of China and Russia. Okay.
But this is how the game is structured.
Of course if the United States doesn't
like you, what it can do is not allow
you to play this game. And these
countries of course would be North Korea
and Iran among other countries. Okay.
So, China and Russia isn't happy about
the system, but at least they get to
play. Iran and North Korea are not even
allowed to play the game of the global
economy. All right. Now, of course, you
can't have people believing that, okay,
this entire global economy is structured
so that the west can steal resources
from everyone else. Okay? So what you do
is you create another layer called the
rulesbased national order. Okay,
multilateral organizations which
includes the UN and the WTO. Okay, world
organization. Okay, this this is called
the rulesbased
international order. But it's really
controlled by the empire. Okay. So so
all all these are just basically shadows
on the wall that the empire is creating
projecting. Okay. to fool us into
behaving the way the empire wants. All
right. So now that you have the system
in place, what you need to do is
indoctrinate people into believing that
the system is fair, just and good. Okay?
And you do that through three
mechanisms. These three mechanisms of
course are education,
um media and culture,
right? What is education? Well, schools
guys and universities, academia,
you think that you go to university to
learn knowledge. No, you don't. You go
to university to be brainwashed into
believe that the system is not just
fear, but actually what really makes
this system work is um the rules based
natural order. Okay, you think about
empire. So that's education. Then of
course you have media which is um CNN,
BBC, New York Times. Each time you read
an article, you think you're receiving
news. You're not receiving news. You're
being brainwashed into believing that
this order is fair, just, and
appropriate. Okay? A phrase that you'll
keep on hearing over and over is rules
based natural order. Okay? But it's not
a rules based in natural order. It's
cave. It's a deception. And the last of
course is culture, which is Hollywood
and you know, television shows, sitcoms,
okay? things that you ab that that you
absorb every day. There's high culture
and there's low culture. All right? So
these are three mechanisms in which um
this order is basically indoctrinated
into everyone so that you didn't you
don't even know this is a deception.
Okay, you believe that this is reality
itself
and this is all to create um values and
norms.
Okay, just the way you see the world,
which allows for the creation of a legal
structure.
So that if you
break the rules, it's not that the elite
will come after you. They don't have to
come after you because everyone else
will come after you. Okay? If you're
that guy who discovers that this is all
deception, they'll kill you. Okay? Not
the elite, but the people around you
will kill you because you are breaking
their fantasy. Okay? You're destroying
their fantasy. All right? So, this is a
very effective system.
Um the problem though is that you need
to spread the system. Okay. So there's
three problems. Okay. First of all, you
have to protect the system, the status
quo. Then you have to um spread this
system as well. Okay? And you then you
also need to justify the system. And you
do that through three transnational
systems, three transnational
organizations. And these are
okay
first of course is intelligence. What is
intelligence? Spies. Okay.
Their job is to infiltrate other nations
elites
and co-opt them into the system. That's
what that's what their job is. Okay.
That's what intelligence does. Then you
have crime.
crime um just engages in the most
profitable enterprises which includes of
course drugs,
human trafficking
and something called money laundering.
Okay.
And this is a way to incentivize the
global elite to work together.
Okay. So that's the first two. And then
there's one more mechanism called
science.
Now you think that science is about
pursuing the truth. No, it's not. Okay?
Science is fundamentally about
finding evidence to justify and protect
the status quo. Okay? That's why science
is fundamentally materialistic.
Okay? Right? And what so if we so we
have to remember like this system is
trying to create values right and these
three major values is
um something called the open society
okay what is open society it's just
basically globalization multiculturalism
the right diversity is good why is it
good because it's good we don't know
it's good okay do you understand they
never find a reason but it's always well
you believe it, it means you're racist,
which is bad. Okay, so uh open society.
Um second is the idea of privat
privatization.
Okay, or we call neoliberalism or free
market, meaning that
governments suck at what they do.
Therefore, you should allow private
entrepreneurs to control everything.
Okay, this idea of neol liberalism again
there's not much evidence to support
this but if you don't believe this it
means you're a communist okay which is
bad by the way and the last thing of
course is consumerism
okay so consumerism is just like how do
you prove your value in life how do you
pursue purpose and meaning in life buy
things man okay and then put on
Instagram so that people can like like
it. You know, that's that's the value of
life, man. Make as much money as
possible and then buy a yacht, get a get
like a super hot girlfriend and then
broadcast it on Instagram and then
you're a hero. Okay. Of course, what
people don't discuss is that this system
is making people lonely, miserable,
depressed, suicidal.
But well, it's because they're not
taking enough drugs, right? If you're
depressed, you should take any
depressence and that will solve the
issue. Right? Okay.
So, because intelligence, crime, and
science are above the nation state,
okay, you need other mechanisms to
actually operate these three things. And
these and so what allows for the system
to work is a collection of elites. Okay?
And um you can break you up break them
down into three groups. First you have
transational capital.
So think of you know finance
Then you have secret societies
and then you have uh families. Okay. So
elite families.
All right. And these three uh
organizations themselves are bounded by
something called the occult.
And we'll discuss this later on. Okay.
The occult. They call it just basically
hidden secret knowledge not available to
people that comes from three places well
other places as well but but we'll look
at three places okay hermetic philosophy
the Bible and the cabala okay we'll
we'll discuss this later on don't worry
too much about the occult right now I'll
show you what the cult is later on but
this is how the system works all right
so there's certain questions about this
the first question is okay well if this
is True. Why is
this system separate from this system?
Right? Why not just say that the occult
is the basis of everything and then you
have the the elite and then you have
science, intelligence, crime and then
you have the empire. Okay, the reason
why is this this is really important for
you guys to understand. This is the
parasite.
Okay, this is the parasite. It doesn't
actually create anything. All it does is
suck up value, extract value.
Okay. And this is the host.
So in fact, these are two separate
systems, right? This is the host and
this is the parasite.
Then your next question would be, okay,
let's just assume this is true. What
evidence is there that this actually
works? Because there should be people
that operate this system, right? Well, I
will give you some names. Okay. All
right. So,
if it is true that this system is the
way it is, there should be individuals
in plays that operate the system, right?
Well, I'll give you some names. I'll
give you two names. Jeffrey Epstein
and Jared Kushner.
Okay? And I'll explain who they are as
we go along.
and
these families help the Rothschild
serious society
chabat blue loop bridge
all right
and you're like this is all conspiracy
this can't be true well it's all true
and I will give you the evidence that
this is all true later on by the way
some of you will be like they're all
Jews man say the Jews rule the world
Well, because um the answer that we have
implicates these people who are Jewish,
but there are other people who are more
powerful who are able to maintain
themselves in the shadows. Okay. So,
it's not really fair to say that it's a
Jewish conspiracy. Okay. I think this
explanation, this uh uh system is much
actually much more complicated than just
saying it's all Jews. All right.
All right. So now what what I want to
discuss is
um the problems of this system. All
right. And once you understand the
problems of this system then we
understand why this war in Iran is
happening where it's going and what this
means for the world. Okay. So there
certain problems with this system I want
you to notice. The first major problem
is all this is based on empire. The
perception of empire. And what this
means is that everyone has to believe
that the American empire is invincible.
It cannot be defeated for the system to
work. Right? Once people start to
believe that their alternatives, that
the empire is weak, then the system
cannot work.
And so therefore, the only solution to
this problem is America has to go fight
wars for no reason. Do you understand?
It's like being the school bully, right?
People pay you money because they think
that you're a bully and you are not
reasonable.
And so to prove that, every now and then
you have to go beat another kid for no
reason. Okay? You just like just smack
the kid. Everyone's afraid of you.
That's America. And that's this helps us
explain all these wars in the Middle
East these past 20 years, right? Why did
America invade Afghanistan? Why did
America invade Iraq? Why did it blow up
Syria? Why did they blow up Libya?
Why? Why are they attacking Iran? To
prove to the world that I'm still the
biggest baddest bully on the block. So,
you better obey me or I'll come beat you
up. Okay. All right.
So, um that's the first problem. Second
problem is that the system as you as you
as you can see is really really unfair
to a lot of countries. Iran, North
Korea, Russia specifically.
Okay. So, this helps us to understand
why Russia invaded Ukraine in 2022
because they're trying to
renegotiate the system, right? Because
right now the system is discriminated
against them. It's extracting their
resources for very little money. So,
they want to renegotiate the system. The
way you renegotiate the system is by
showing the empire is not so tough,
right? And this but this also shows us
why America refuses to surrender
Ukraine. This war was lost about 2 years
ago. Okay? Ukraine has actually no
chance. Why is this war continuing?
Because if the perception that empire is
weak, that empire can be defeated. If
that perception um if people are aware
of this, this entire edifice collapses.
Okay? Right? people wake up and see it's
all shadows on the wall. So America has
no choice but to keep on fighting. Okay.
And this helps us al this helps us also
explain why America invaded Iran to show
Russia I'm still the biggest baddest
bully. And now we understand what Iran
is doing. Iran is now attacking this
entire edifice. If you think about it
what Iran recognizes is this. I cannot
attack empire directly. Okay? It's too
powerful. They have nuclear weapons. I'm
not going to attack the education,
media, cultural system of America
because it's too embedded. I'm not I
can't attack the UN and WTO because it's
all being controlled by America. So the
only thing I can attack is what? The
global economy, right? That's why they
closed off the street moves because once
they put pressure on the global economy
and that's all interconnected, it
destroys the entire edifice. You
understand? It is a house of cards. You
find the weak point and you hit it. So
it all collapses. Okay? And that's why
Iran is doing what it's doing. And what
this also tells us is this. There can be
no ceasefire.
There can be no truce. There can be no
peace because both the American Empire
and Iran are fighting for the nature and
structure of reality itself.
All right.
And the third thing I want you guys to
be aware of of is is this remember alleg
with the cave? They really don't really
have to do anything because the
prisoners themselves want to protect the
system. Well, this is true as well where
if you are in education, media and
culture and you are at the very top, you
are not in power but you benefit from
the system and therefore you insist on
protecting the system at all costs. And
these people of course are called the
boomers.
Okay.
Okay. Not all of them. Okay. But the
elite of the boomers, even though they
themselves don't have that much power,
there's a lot of them, okay? And they
will fight. They will make their
politicians and the military fight to
the death to maintain the illusion of
empire which benefits them.
All right. Again, Plato's alley of the
cave.
Okay. All right. So um now we can answer
all three questions. Why did this war
start? Because America had no choice in
the matter. Okay. It had to defend the
illusion that the American empire was
invincible. Otherwise this entire
edifice would collapse. Okay. When will
this war end? This war ends when the
global economy is destroyed.
Because once the global economy is
destroyed, this entire edifice
collapses.
Okay? And what will happen after this
war? Well, a new world will emerge where
there are different um spirits of
influence. Okay? But we'll discuss this
later on. But I first introduce to you
the big structure of what's going on.
Okay? All right. So now what I want to
do is I want to go more into the
structure of this world. Okay. This
what I want to show you is Jeff Epstein
is one of the operators of the system.
He works for the Rothschild
as well as civil societies as well as
capital Capital and he is embedded in
science crime and intelligence. Okay.
And again the evidence is something
called the Epstein files. All right. So
let's look at the Epstein files.
Okay. So this is um Jeffy Epstein and
this is Donald Trump. All right.
Jeff Epstein died in 2019 in a federal
prison
and he was on he was being charged with
um
um many crimes and it's and the FBI ran
an investigation into him and just
recently the United States called the
Department of Justice the DOJ on their
website they released about 3 million
documents pertaining to the epine
investigation and a lot of these are
emails
And what you discover is that he knows
everyone who's powerful in the world. So
for the longest time it was believed
that Jeffrey Epstein was a Mossad agent.
Okay? and his job was to lure powerful
American um powerful Americans such as
Bill Gates, Bill Clinton to his island
called Epstein Island where he would
film them engage in compromising
activities
and then he would blackmail them. Okay?
And that was for the longest time what
people understood to be Jeff Epstein's
role. And then you but then when you
look at the emails what you recognize is
that no actually that's what he did for
fun. Actually he made most of his money
in arms trafficking and in money
laundering. Also Bill Gates wasn't going
to uh Epstein Island uh to give Jeff
Epstein money. Jeff Epstein w he went to
ask for money. Think about this. Okay.
Bill Gates at once um before the
wealthiest man in the world. He was
begging Jeff Epstein for money.
Think about that.
All right. Okay. So, let us
look at who he is. Okay. This is Peter
Theo. Peter Theo, as you know, is one of
the wealthiest men in America. and Peter
Theo and Jeff Epstein are arranging a
time to meet. Again, it is not Jeffrey
Epstein is seeking these guys out.
They're seeking him out. Okay. Ellen
Musk, the wealth the wealthiest man in
the world. He's actually trying to
arrange an appointment with Jeffrey
Epstein. All right. Why? Because Jeffrey
Epstein says, "I represent the
Rothschild." All right. Your money is
fake. Your money, stock market money,
your money is an illusion. I represent
real money, real power, real wealth.
Okay. All right. The Roths. All right.
So, Jeffy Epstein is very close with the
Rothschaw family. Why? Well, this is
Arena de Rothschild, one of the members
of the Roshaw family. Okay. And um in
December 2018, okay, this is a year
before he dies. All right. Um, Jeremy
Epstein sends Aaron Deaf an email
saying, "Hey,
let me tell you something really funny.
Harvard is saying that when Hitler was
poor, he lived in a home, a charity home
that was financed by three wealthy
families who are Jewish." And who are
these three wealthy families? They're
the Rothschilds, right? Then they're the
Epstein, me, and the governments. So
these three families Rothschilds,
Epstein's and Gummans going back
centuries. All right. So Epstein is a
member of one of the most powerful
families in the world.
All right. Now um Artha responds and and
says, "Oh, it's just a conspiracy
theory,
right? It's just saying that the Jews
created Hitler." And Epste gets angry at
him and says, "No, it's 100% true, man.
Hitler was selling his clothes and
already living in a shelter funded by
Jewels. Epstein, Ross, and Gutman. No
conspiracy. It's really true." Okay. The
Epste, who are we? We're the Vienna
bankers.
All right. We've been around for the
longest time. You Ross think you're
powerful. Well, we're powerful, too.
Okay.
All right. Let's continue.
All right. So, the FBI is running an
investigation on Jeffrey Epstein and
they create a file on him and there's a
um confidential human source, a spy
basically who they recruit to tell them
who Jeffrey Epstein is and what his
network is. And the FBI is sort of blown
away by what they discover. Okay. So, um
Amber, could you help me read, please?
Okay. All right. All right. So, I want
you to start up a talk and it's a bit
hard to read. Okay. But but try your
best. Okay. Um, Jeffrey Epstein was
was represented by Dur Show.
>> Alan Dersowitz. Okay. Alan Ders is a
Harvard professor.
>> He's he's one of the most powerful men
in America. Okay. Alan Ditz. Keep on
going.
>> CHS remembered Durowitz. tell Alex Okas
Okasa,
>> US attorney of Southern District of
Florida at the time that Epstein
belonged to both uh US and allied
intelligence services.
>> Okay. So, um in 2008, Epstein was
arrested in Florida for um doing
inappropriate behavior. Okay. And George
comes in and says, "Hey, you can't
arrest this guy because he works for
intelligence." Actually, the truth of
the matter is intelligence works for
him. Okay, keep on going.
>> CHS shared phone calls between Deseriz
and Epstein during which he/ she took
notes. After these calls, Mosad would
then call Dowitz to debrief. Epstein was
close to the former prime minister of
Israel, Ud Barrick, and trained as a spy
under him. Barak believed Netanyahu was
a criminal. Saudi Arabia,
Israel, and the United uh Arab Emirates
are allied against Qatar, Turkey, Iran,
and Syria. When
>> Okay. Okay. All right. So, here it says
that Epstein worked for Assad. That's
not true. Okay. All right. So, you look
at Epson's life. He actually started his
career at Dalton. Dalton is one of the
most prestigious elite schools in
America. That's all where all the most
powerful, wealthiest family send their
children. Okay. He was hired as a
teacher. Then he went to work for Bear
Sterns.
Bear Sterns, which is a financial firm.
And there he learned um finance. But
then he went to work for Doug Lee. Who's
Doug Lee? Douglas is an arms trafficker
uh involved with iron contraure. Okay.
So he's one he's one of the biggest
global arms traffickers in the world and
then he worked for uh started to work
for Barack who is the prime minister or
the former prime minister of Israel. All
right. So you're like everyone's like
okay well it's because he sucks
everything and that's why he was being
uh moved from one place to to another.
Okay. But another way another way of
saying this is he's an operative and he
is being trained in how power works by
mentors.
Does that make sense? Let's just say I
have a big company right and I'm a
chairman. My son is going to inherit
this company. How do I train him to be a
good boss? Well, I have him work in
different departments of the company and
I have mentors train him in these
different departments. Right? So what is
D stolen? Daltton is education, right?
What is Beerus Sterns? Finance. What is
Doug Le? He is criminal, arm
trafficking. And who is Bar uh sorry U
Bar? He is intelligence. Right? Does
that make sense, guys? He's being
trained, mentored in the different
sectors of power in the world. All
right. Uh
keep on reading.
Um Masha Dro Dro Dova telephone number
is based in Silicon Valley. She has been
running a film called Day One Ventures,
a firm called Day One Ventures, which is
supposedly an early stage investment
company. She used to be Russian
President Vladimir Putin's main contact
in the Russian youth movement. CHS and
Dro uh DOVA spoke, but Draova did not
talk at all about technology. Instead,
she to looked at CHS and said, "You knew
Epstein, didn't you?" She said Epstein
was a wonderful man.
>> Okay. So, Epstein was connected with
Vladimir Putin. Okay.
>> All right. Uh let's read the last
section. This is most important. Okay.
>> CHS advised Shabbad.
>> Okay. Shabbad, right? The the
organization we talked about. Yes. By
the way,
>> Shabbat is doing everything they can do
to co-opt the Trump presidency. Shabbat
is basically state sanctioned Judaism.
It is used by Putin to keep tabs on all
the Russo Jewish oligarchs. On the day
Trump was elected president, Ivanka
Trump and Jared
>> Kushner
>> uh say Kushner. We keep on going.
>> Mhm. were at the gravesite of Rabbi
>> Snerson.
>> So remember last class I showed you a
video of Nanyahu approaching a rabbi
called Rabbi Snerson and saying will you
give me your blessing and snerson says
yes I will and please hurry up and make
the the Messiah come. Okay so it's all
interconnected. Okay. Nanyahu Snerson uh
the Trump family Putin and all it's it's
all connected through Shabbat Lubovich
and Jeff Epstein. Okay, keep on going.
>> Who was the most powerful rabbi in the
shabed shab shabed network? Um Jared
didn't disclose his stake in Kore
because of its ties to the Russian state
NFI. CHS believed this was is the real
Russian collusion story. Kushner had
moved a lot of Russian investment money
around. The FBI should investigate
Kushner's family charities to find
evidence of corruption and money
laundering. Chev routinely uses char uh
charities to launder money.
>> Great. So this is it guys. Okay, this is
it. The FBI did an investigation. And
what they discovered is that Jeffrey
Epstein and Jerry Kushner are both part
of this transnational network that's
able to co-op different nation states
including Russia, including America and
they're all connected to this other
transnational religious organization
called the Shabbat Lubich and their
leader is Rabbi Sners. It's all one big
network. All right. And um let's look at
this. Okay. This is um a report a secret
government report. What happened was
that when Americans went into
Afghanistan
um the British went into and Prince
Andrew who is the brother to the king
asked the British uh government to
investigate investment opportunities in
Afghanistan. Okay. So this is the
British government and so whatever they
report has to be confidential. It's
basically state secret.
And this report tells Prince Andrew
where the best place to invest in
Afghanistan. And what does Prince Andrew
do? He emails it directly to Jeffrey
Epstein.
Okay.
You think these guys work for the
government, Prince Andrew? No, no, no.
They work for Jeffrey Epstein, who works
for the Rothschilds.
All right. All right. This is Libya. All
right. So, in February 2011, okay, this
is July 2011,
um, America starts bombing Libya and it
seems as though Gaddafi will fall and
already Jeffrey Epste and his friends
are discussing how to make money out of
this, right? Because they know that
Libya has many assets frozen in American
banks. So once a new government comes
into place, then this new government
will want the money back, right? And
Jeff Epstein and his friends are like,
let's do this for them and get a
commission,
right? Can can you read? Um
>> Mhm. Understood. Remember, there are
already 880 billion in frozen funds/
assets internationally, of which 32.4
billion is in the US. And it is
estimated that the real number is
somewhere between three to four times
this number in sovereign stolen and
misappropriated assets. So if we can
identify slash recover 5% to 10% of
these money uh monies and receive 10% to
25% as compensation we are talking about
billions of dollars. But the real carrot
is if we can become their go-to go-to
guys because they plan to spend at least
a hundred billion dollars next year to
rebuild their country and jumpstart the
economy. Also remember Libya is a rich
country as its population is 2 million
less than the city of New York and it
has the ninth largest crude oil and
natural gas reserves on the planet and a
literacy rate of almost 80%.
>> Okay. Do you guys do you guys understand
those what's happening? Okay, these are
parasites. They look at geopolitics and
they're like, "How can we take advantage
of geopolitical advance to make the most
money for ourselves?" All right. And
you're like, "Okay, well, Jeffrey
Epstein is gone." Sorry. Okay. All
right. So, something else I I want to
discuss with you is Bitcoin. Okay. So,
this is a Guardian article, a Guardian
article that shows that Jeffrey Epstein
was helping to finance development of
Bitcoin. All right. But not only that, I
I want to show you this picture. This
this happened in 2004 at Harvard. Okay,
this is Larry Summers who is the
president of Harvard University. This is
Steven Pinker, one of Harvard's most
famous scholars. And this guy is Jeffrey
Epste. All right. Who's paying for this
dinner? Probably Jeff Jeffrey Epste. And
you're like, what is happening here? And
again, I keep on telling you guys this.
You think academia is about pursuing
truth, doing research. No, it's not.
It's about
protecting and just justifying the
status quo. It's about providing a
network for powerful people to meet
together and to work together. Okay. And
the Jeff Files reveals this how corrupt
academia and science are. It's all part
of this huge transational network, this
grand alliance between science, crime,
and intelligence in order to extract as
much value from the world as possible.
Okay, these are parasites. And you're
like, okay, how about Jerk Kushner?
Well, Jerk Kushner is doing the same
thing, guys. Okay, this is Jared
Kushner, right? Who's this guy?
Vladimir Putin. What are they doing?
They're discussing peace in Ukraine.
Because what Jared Kushner is saying to
Putin is listen I can negotiate okay I'm
speculating okay I I don't know okay but
I imagine he's a real estate developer
so he's saying to Putin hey after this
peace treaty happens between Ukraine and
Russia Ukraine will need to be
redeveloped so you should give
opportunities to you know you know okay
that's Russia
then you go to
Iran
This is Jer Ker, Steve Woff and the
Omani foreign minister. And before the
attack against Iran happened, there were
these peace negotiations between the
Iranians and Jerk Kushner and Steve
Wukov who represent the Americans. This
guy Steve Wilkov during the negotiations
went on TV and said that oh the Iranians
are trying to um create a uh they're
trying to enrich weapons grade uranium
as soon as possible. Okay. So what
StephVov is doing is he's sabotaging the
peace negotiations.
These guys are negotiating with Iranians
not to create a peace treaty but to
create a justification for war.
All right. Oh, and also this is um
J Kushner. Sorry.
Oh crap. All right. This is
J Kushner. This is Steve and this is
Benjamin. What are they doing? They're
discussing peace in Gaza. Why? Because
after peace happens in Gaza, Steve
Whipov and Joe Kusha are going to lead a
real estate team to develop Gaza into
these luxury villas, guys. Okay.
So, this is how the world works.
All right. But again
there's a problem with the system. All
right. So okay well this is the way the
world works. Now the question then is
okay if this is the way the world works
and JC and Jar Kushner and others are
the real power in the world and they
represent the elite. How do we know
this? Why is the Epstein files in like
out in the government website? Right?
Why is it that you can go on the
Department of Justice and look at all
these things? Well, because there's a
problem with this system.
This and it's this
this system is a parasite,
right? So, they are extracting value
from the nation state. So, other elites
are asking themselves, why can't they be
the parasites but not us?
Right? So what's happening is a civil
war between the elite, these people, and
the counter elite, people who want to
take the position and become the
parasites. Okay? And that's why we're
seeing this conflict right now um emerge
in America,
right? Any questions, guys?
Any questions? All right. So we will
discuss this civil conflict, this civil
war next class.